I have a voicemail number you can call
anytime 2192 David P here is a caller
who is again confused about whether or
not I am a socialist listen to this
did you just misspeak I thought I just
heard you say that you are a Social
Democrat right don't you mean to say you
are a Democratic Socialist no would that
be more accurate no no I didn't misspeak
sir I am not a Democratic Socialist
Democratic socialism is a form of
Socialism
I am a Social Democrat which is a
well-regulated form of capitalism I did
not misspeak I am not a socialist some
on the right and even some on the left
think I am a socialist but I'm not
I'm not criticizing socialism in this
segment I'm just saying I'm not
socialist it's sort of like if you say
David didn't you say you were black and
I would go no I didn't say I was black
I'm not black oh so you don't like black
people no I'm not saying that I'm just
saying I happen not to be black that's
all I'm saying okay I'm not a socialist
please
um okay we have a great bonus show for
you today we are going to talk about the
apoplectic reaction to Rihanna's Super
Bowl performance we are going to talk
about lawmakers or as Donald Trump once
called them La markers focusing in on
chat GPT in the uh in this growing
popularity for the tool and we are going
to talk about a bill from Bernie Sanders
to boost Social Security benefits not
cut but rather boost all of those
stories and more are on the bonus show
thank your lucky stars every day you're
not Dave Pacman well I get to host the
bonus show Alex so that's an exciting
thing sign up at joinpakman.com I will
see you then